[Music]
the david pakman show
at davidpakman.com
welcome to the bonus show there's an
interesting new type of protest that's
going on against coronavirus
stay-at-home
orders and social distancing guidelines
and it's in lansing michigan
and uh stay-at-home order protesters
have been giving people haircuts on the
lawn
of the michigan state capitol now i have
to tell you pat
this is not a bad idea in the sense that
like if you
the the the contagion happening outdoors
is
very very small and i've talked before
about how
ninety percent of the contagion is
happening um at home
and at indoor workplaces and on public
transit
and then the other ten percent is
disproportionately also happening
indoors like if you said to me
hey how can we do haircuts if we are
determined to do them
i would say do them outdoors and of
course have the the person cutting the
hair
wear a mask like i understand that these
protests are meant to be
cartoonish and get attention and the
protesters are wacky
but outdoor haircuts strike me as a way
to get back to haircuts sooner than
later
well i think for most of us outdoors
implies that you're out in the open like
you're out walking in a park and there's
a bunch of space between you and the
next person
yes but with these protesters they are
kind of huddled together of course and
if you have all these haircuts i mean
you can't have a socially distant
haircut you can
both have the the person cutting the
hair and person getting their hair cut
wear a mask
and do basic things like that but i mean
there's still a lot of touching and the
chance for transmissions
when it comes to that stuff uh here in
massachusetts we're gonna have barber
shops and hairdressers
open back up next week uh so i'm not
gonna say that like michigan is
um doing the complete wrong here by by
having people go out and cut
uh hair in the plazas but um yeah
i think you still have to be responsible
with this for sure yeah there were i
think most of the people were not
wearing masks and there were people
crowded around it became a spectacle so
on and so forth but
in in all complete seriousness if
someone came with a proposal and said
listen
first of all let me talk about haircuts
haircuts have become another badge
political badge sort of like the mask
where you know ted cruz
went and got a haircut and it became a
big thing and he defied a state order
and
sean hannity praised him but said also
thank you for wearing the math yeah
the haircut let's let's put aside for a
second
how the haircut has become another
political badge if you
said hey listen haircuts are going to
make people feel better
it is an industry that could come back
uh
we want to see if we can do it safely
if someone said here's the proposal you
put a single chair
out in an outdoor space and
it's one person at a time it's by
appointment only
people aren't huddled around the person
doing the haircut
is going to properly you know they're
going to change masks between
clients they're going to you know have
enough five sets of shears and combs and
stuff so you're not just like throwing
them in the barbicide between
people you're actually getting a new set
of equipment
it's not a terrible idea for getting
people haircuts and bringing back a
feeling of normality now to be clear
that's not what these protesters are
calling for yeah i mean don't you think
that a lot of these people are just
being babies though
like they just want to go and get a
haircut they want to get their roots
done
and it's really just a way to to to make
a scene and you know it's not like
they're really even suffering all that
much individually it seems like
you know the people who are actually
suffering are the people who have the
virus or who lost their jobs because of
the shutdowns
the people who have to wait another two
months to get a haircut you know it's
kind of unfortunate but just put a hat
on or something it's low on the list
i totally agree i guess my point is this
i would respect
a lot of these protesters way more if
they said hey listen
we're going to be part of the solution
we have a proposal
for how we could do outdoor haircuts and
we want to work with you rather than
doing it as this
angry protest sometimes with guns i
would respect them if they came and did
that like listen
there was an idea from this the dilbert
creator scott adams who blocked me on
twitter now after we had like a twitter
war a few weeks ago
whatever i don't care i don't take it
personally he seemed he seemed to be
very very angry at me personally for for
some broader frustrations i think maybe
he was experiencing okay
he had an idea that i thought was
interesting which was hey
it's starting to get warmer and more and
more of the country there are lots of
outdoor seating areas that restaurants
have
what about just to make things feel a
little more normal
the outdoor seating areas can be open
there's no table service
it's it's disposable utensils just like
if you were taking takeout
but you can sit there with a reduced
capacity the risk of infection from that
is extraordinarily low
and there might be an emotional victory
there or
there have been better proposals which
say this is tougher in the u.s
because european cities are better set
up for this but
the plazas extend the area where people
can sit
into some of these public spaces more
significantly new york
and boston have some of these there's
some other cities that do and let
restaurants
again allow people to sit there with a
very limited
crowding and just have their take out
like i these things are they they're
stupid in the sense that this is not
life or death but if you did all of
these things
a lot of people are ignoring stay at
home anyway maybe this would give people
something
safe to do and get them to otherwise be
compliant right those are very much
reasonable proposals
and as long as adults are making those
proposals i'm definitely willing to
listen to them certainly with these
protesters they're just trying to make a
scene they're not trying to actually
make headway with this stuff i think
they're just trying to
uh you know make their statement act
like they're martyrs and all that stuff
but you're right there are definitely
things like that we can start to
consider and haircuts
is one of them i actually have a haircut
appointment for next friday do you
remember that it's going to be a big day
for all of us yeah i'm thinking maybe
thursday for the bonus show i'll spike
my hair up so i can see
just how long it grew uh and then maybe
before you get your
uh haircut you can do the same thing as
well yeah i have not yet
really i mean listen obviously if you
watch the show with any frequency you
know i sort of do need a haircut but
it's not like an urgent need
i was not thinking necessarily of
getting one next week but so you're
going to your normal place you called
and you made an appointment
not a normal place uh but some place
that i was able to find online you have
to make an appointment to get a haircut
you can't uh just walk in
uh so yeah i have it scheduled and i'm
gonna wear my mask that's for sure
and i know that's gonna make me feel
better too so i think that'll be one of
those things that helped me but now hold
on
so you have to take the mask off during
the haircut right otherwise i don't cut
it
well i was thinking you know maybe
getting around the ears would be kind of
tough but like i was i was expecting i
was just going to keep the mask on they
didn't say i had to wear a mask on the
whole time but i thought i would just do
that anyway
that sounds like it'll be difficult they
will be wearing a mask though right
hopefully i would i would assume i think
state the state the state guidelines are
that they have to okay well
we'll check in about pat's haircut next
week clearly a very very big week
upcoming next week that's for sure uh so
we have another instance of one of these
kind of weird contracts
being handed out or to a company that is
connected to donald trump there's a con
construction company
that has repeatedly been touted by
donald trump
and they just got a 1.2 billion dollar
contract to participate in border wall
construction and refurbishment the north
dakota company
is called fisher sand and gravel they
were given the contract on may 6th
first reported by the arizona daily star
and
the deal is part of the company's
december border contract worth 400
million dollars
the defense department inspector general
is still reviewing this
thanks to a request from congress and
listen i
i don't know that we will ever know for
sure pat
um whether these are corrupt deals or
not
and that's why this stuff often goes
without consequences because it's like
listen you look at the data
trump talks about this company his
allies talk about this company the
company companies in north dakota
why are they going to get a contract to
do something on the southern border
they could barely be further from the
southern border than they are in north
dakota
but they have a footprint in arizona in
the asphalt
drilling and blasting industry so like
there's enough plausible deniability
where it would be very difficult to
ever definitively say this is a smoking
gun
but they're a relatively small [ __ ]
company and
they have a lack of experience in wall
building so i think those two things
raise eyebrows especially when you're
talking about a billion dollar plus
contract
also they've been cited 16 times for
environmental violations over the years
uh
the company has been fined for workplace
safety infractions and sexual
assault allegations so it's perfect um
yeah and also michael fisher the former
head of the company he pled guilty to
nine counts of felony tax fraud
and received 37 months in federal prison
that's a long time that's all bad
but that doesn't mean it's trump-related
corruption necessarily
oh of course no i'm sure they're totally
playing by the book with this one
so i i again we saw so if we go back
there was that company from montana that
got a really huge deal
in the puerto rico hurricane recovery
and it stunk to high heaven and
eventually puerto rico canceled the
contract
we talked a couple weeks ago about the
company that was getting a huge deal
to be a middleman for n95 masks
and they their parent company was
bankrupt and had no employees
and that was really weird and they were
charging about 10x per mask
for the deal on today's broadcast show
um or tomorrow's rather i'm going to be
talking about
a another company that uh is getting a
deal
to do raw materials for possible
coronavirus treatments here in the
united states and it's a very weird deal
they are brand new they've been around
for four months so it's like
put another one on the list and i i just
i don't want to be cynical but this is
only stopping
if we vote this guy out yeah it's
impossible to stop all these corrupt
deals because i'm sure they're making
new corrupt deals every
week or so and it takes months to
investigate those corrupt deals so
you're always playing from behind
also you would think that the talk about
the wall would uh calm down a little bit
now because the whole reason they want
to build a wall is because mexicans are
coming here and taking our job
they're not going to come because of the
virus and also there doesn't seem to be
that many jobs available
right now so yeah and also we don't
really have that much money to be
spending on these extra side pet
projects right now like the wall is so
you know
shouldn't they just move this wall topic
to down the road shouldn't it not be a
campaign issue this time
i think it is trump deliberately setting
himself
up to be able to tout accomplishments as
we get close to november
he probably sees the writing on the wall
that you know maybe coronavirus will be
better
in november but we might be in wave two
or it might never go away
we i the economy we could get absolutely
disastrous second quarter gdp numbers
people are talking about 20 25 30. i saw
one estimate that's 35 percent
decline in q2 possible i think he's just
trying to set himself up to have stuff
to talk about
are you saying that building the wall
isn't about doing what's best for the
country but rather to make trump look
good i can't believe that
someone sent me a graduation speech
trump gave like
a decade ago where he says if you know
never give up
if you come up on a concrete wall go
around it
go over it and of course it had nothing
to do with undocumented immigration but
now that he's the build the wall guy
there was something
hysterically poetic about it i loved how
in 2016
you would frequently talk about how he
was gonna have this big beautiful wall
and at one time he in real time realized
the flaw in the wall
which is that you can uh have a ladder
that goes up to the top of the wall
and then a rope that brings you down
because he thought initially once you
get to the top of the wall you're just
gonna be stuck there then you realize oh
well if you have a rope then i guess
you're gonna be fine
um so that totally like disproved his
wall argument and i loved that glitch
because he realized it in real time
i'm gonna have to find that one i
remember talking about that there we
will be doors in the wall which was also
an interesting one
hey so listen we talked last week i
guess it was or maybe it was
a year ago it's hard to tell right now
but um paul manafort
is uh was is being or maybe has already
been released from prison because of
coronavirus
fears uh he is one of the people who was
imprisoned
in the entire trump russia scandal
another person is michael cohen now
remember michael cohen was trump's
personal attorney
cohen uh did cooperate paul manafort
didn't so we were expecting maybe
manafort would be pardoned and cohen
wouldn't but it turns out cohen
is going to be released to serve the
rest of his sentence
at home again because of concerns about
coronavirus
at fci otisville in new york
not really a huge surprise at this point
yeah and when we saw that manafort was
getting out but we didn't know if cohen
would get out we thought maybe
there was a double standard here because
uh you know cohen wasn't loyal to trump
at the end whereas manafort stayed loyal
to trump you know is that the reason why
one's getting out and the other isn't uh
it doesn't seem to be that
as much now maybe it's just maybe the
double standard is a power uh double
standard you know michael cohen's still
this like rich successful guy and so
that's why he's able to get out because
he has the lawyers to do so
um so i think you know it's hard to
imagine that trump would have
the leverage to um influence like the
criminal justice system at like sort of
the local level like in new york or
whatever
so i don't think it was necessarily the
the ties to trump that got manafort out
early i really just think it's the rich
poor divide
yeah and just the the the manafort being
first could just be related to
just logistical bureaucratic and
administrative stuff too
could be could be his age right cohen is
53 whereas manafort i believe is
70ish something like that at least 70
yeah and in worse health certainly than
michael cohen
at least as far as we've been led to
believe although sometimes in these
cases the claims of poor health can be
exaggerated as we saw with harvey
weinstein's walker
uh while on weekends he would sometimes
be spotted without it getting around
relatively well at various
department stores and that sort of thing
but we don't know we don't know
could have just been feeling better that
day yeah it's unfortunate how sometimes
those ailments just sort of flare up
like sometimes my knee bothers me but
other than that
only yeah my knee is horrible
um okay so anyway not a huge surprise
there and of course a lot of this does
have to do
with the um uh privilege of being in
these
the place michael cohen is in from what
i understand is really pretty nice like
they have a lot of amenities
and it is very very different than what
we would call
a state penitentiary state pen as they
are often
referred to all right that does it for
today we'll have a new show
and a new bonus show coming up tomorrow
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]